bob dylan infamously said you gotta
serve somebody
who are you serving find out on this
episode of
led live
light exposing darkness
hey everyone welcome back to led live
we're so glad you could join us again we
have our guest eric
wilson with us today thank you eric how
are you i'm doing well
good to see you guys it's good to have
you on the show well this is
part two in a two-part series first part
we talked about
the kingdom of light and talking about
the serpent's whisper
and um so today we're going to talk
about those two kingdoms
and i'm i'm remembering this um
this single that bob dylan put out
called gotta serve somebody
yes i remember that and in
the chorus are some interesting lyrics
he says but you're gonna have to serve
somebody
yes indeed you're gonna have to serve
well it may be the devil or it may be
the lord
but you're gonna have to serve somebody
you know and that really agrees
with what the bible says it says no man
can serve
two masters you know it says you'll
you'll
love one but you'll hate the other
right yes so
um as the serpent is whispering
to us you know we talked about in the
first episode
the different messages right what what
voice
are you listening to so let's talk about
some of those voices today
okay um in our last message
we were looking at those two kingdoms
and we began with the kingdom of light
both sides of the great controversy
are playing by the same rules and it's
amazing
because jesus tells us in john chapter
six
it's a powerful chapter if you want to
do something fun for a couple of weeks
spend every morning reading john chapter
six read it out loud
um jesus actually said
i am the word and i'm also the bread
that came down from heaven
man doesn't live by bread alone but by
every word that proceeds out of the
mouth of god
literally so that means that
i have to make a choice of of who
i'm going to serve and it's not just
serving it's like
let me think how to put this it's like
somebody getting
in the water 100 feet deep out in the
middle of the pacific ocean it's
gorgeous they're going scuba diving
and they go scuba diving they get under
the water and they look over at their
instructor and they say
i don't need the regulator anymore
i don't need that the moment you take
the regulator out of your mouth
you're dead you're dead
that's a person that says i don't need
jesus i can just live on my own i'm not
going to serve the devil i'm not going
to serve god i'm just going to be
you don't understand the moment you take
the word of god
out of your life you die no and you may
be a dead man walking for 30 40 60 years
but you're dead
you're dead but praise god if we eat
the word of god and we we take it and we
make it part of us you know god's word
tells us something in
first john chapter 3 it says beloved
now today you are the sons and daughters
of god
and i go but i don't feel like i am
but if if i read it i go yeah but god
said it and god can't lie
that means i really am a son of god
that changes you that gives you the
power and the strength and the
inspiration to stand up and
walk as a conqueror as a son of god
so we have to like like he said we're
gonna serve somebody
there is no middle ground i remember ken
ham from the creation museum he came to
our city
and he gave a a lecture there and it was
it was amazing because
it was in the middle of the week and my
wife was like nobody's going to show up
because everybody's in school all the
children are in school
we got there and there was over 5 000
young people
grades eight and down wow that showed up
because their teachers in tennessee
didn't care about what the school
regulations said they said we're going
on a field trip today
and they took their students there and
you know what ken ham said
said he said if somebody tries to tell
you
listen you step off of your christian
ground come out into the middle i'll
step
off of my atheist ground and come to the
middle and let's talk about facts let's
talk about science
he said there is no middle ground the
moment you step off the word of god
you're standing on the devil's ground
there's only two sides
so today we're going to be looking at
how satan
is seeking to gain the kingdom of god
that's within us
in isaiah chapter 14 verse 12 through 14
and this is a familiar verse it says
speaking of satan
after he fell from heaven it says for
thou hast
said in thine heart i will ascend into
heaven
i will exalt my throne above the stars
of god
i will sit also upon the mount
of the congregation in the sides of the
north
i will be like the most high what many
christians don't realize is it says i
will sit upon the mount of the
congregation
read daniel chapter 9 daniel says
thy mountain and thy holy city and thy
people
are all one and the same he calls the
people of god mount zion
we are the mountain of god we are the
mount
of the congregation the congregation
it's us
satan said i'm going to put my throne
where god's is supposed to be
inside men's hearts and women's hearts
now i'm going to read a statement here
this was a powerful statement that came
out of
right after the great reformation the
protestant reformation
it comes from a news article called
review in herald april 14
1896 and also a little book called
ministry of healing
it says the forces of darkness will
unite with human agents
who have given themselves into the
control of satan
and the same scenes that were exhibited
at the trial
rejection and crucifixion of christ will
be revived
that's what you were talking about in
our last meeting
through yielding to satanic
influences people go i wouldn't i
wouldn't yield to the devil
i'm sitting there at 11 o'clock at night
and all of a sudden i'm watching a a
good christian show on tv and a
commercial comes on
pound cake and i go oh man we've got
pound cake and it's 11 o'clock at night
and the lord is whispering to me eric
you don't need pound cake at 11 o'clock
at night
and the enemy through my stomach is
saying yeah but it would be really good
one bite won't kill you that's the same
thing he told
you know eve just one bite it won't kill
you god won't surely kill you for this
one little thing
but if i yield to that influence rather
than the influence of god
i become his slave
it says through yielding to satanic
influences men
and women will be transformed into
fiends that means devils
and those who were created in the image
of god who were
formed to honor and create glorify our
creator will become
the habitation of dragons
you see that picture of that man reading
that book you know behind us and that
dragon
over his shoulder he's becoming
possessed with that spirit
i just have to do a plug because of the
t-shirt here
made in the image of god hallelujah
that's right
but it is interesting the image of god
not necessarily being
just an outward appearance of it but
but actually the character of god
imprinted upon us do you know in romans
chapter 8 it tells
us that the entire universe
is waiting for one event the
manifestation of the sons and daughters
of god
god created us to be his sons and
daughters
and we read last time that everything
that was lost by the first adam is fully
restored by the second
so god is waiting for us to take hold of
his promise
that says i have forgiven you i have
washed you
i want you to stand up and walk clean
and free
amen
i'm going to finish this quote this one
really struck me this
this illustration because i used to be
involved heavily in the martial arts and
keith was too
and both of us were involved in the
chinese martial arts
this is a monk from the shaolin temple
that came to the united states
and he says he fled for uh asylum here
you know
that that's a joke i mean like really
the shaolin temple has said we want to
send our monks into
all the world to evangelize the world
they call them evangelical
wow the buddhists are very evangelical
so are the hindus
interesting but the quote says and satan
will see in an apostate race
his masterpiece of evil men and women
who reflect his own image
and it's funny because this picture of
this shaolin monk in new york city
that is his temple that he teaches his
school his martial arts school
that picture on the wall behind him is
what spirit
he allows to empower him
[Music]
in revelation chapter 12 and i'm going
to turn there
it talks about this dragon
it calls it that old serpent called the
devil and satan
revelation chapter 12 verse 7 through
11.
it says there was war in heaven michael
and his angels
fought against the dragon and the dragon
fought
and his angels and prevailed not praise
god
amen neither was their place
found anymore in heaven and the great
dragon was cast
out that old serpent called the devil
or adversary and satan the accuser
which deceives the whole world
he was cast out into the earth and his
angels
were cast out with him this is a big
deal
we know from the bible that there were
billions
of holy angels and one third of them
fell
with satan so we've got billions
don't know how many it wouldn't surprise
me i don't know this for a fact that it
wouldn't surprise me if there was
one fallen angel for almost every human
being on the planet
they're keeping tabs on you just like
the cia would do you know i've got a
folder
and if this angel has to get called to
another mission a new angel comes in to
take his place he hands him the stack of
manila boulders and says here's the file
on this guy i've been watching him
and his parents for three generations so
if you need to know how to get him go to
page 42 in that second folder and it'll
show you that's his easiest
trick yeah that pound cake yeah
and this is something i know we we've
talked about before but when you look up
the word
angel in hebrew it means
a messenger or one who dispatches
messages a messenger yeah
so satan and his messengers were cast
out
right and messengers send messages
messages are made up of what
words words isn't that funny jesus
is the word of god and he has holy
angels
that means messages of holiness messages
of life
messages of peace messages of love
messages
of obedience and of victory and and
satan has the exact opposite
the word spirits in the hebrew means
wind or breath by extension a region of
the sky
and that's interesting let me show you
why
in revelation 14 god has three
angels that are sent down from heaven in
the last days the time we're living in
to give the message of the glad tidings
of the kingdom of god
of his reign and also to warn the world
of the supplanter the deceiver
and then in revelation 16 we see satan
has the same thing
it says i saw three unclean spirits
like frogs come out of the mouth of the
dragon
when you ask a child about a frog or you
say show me what a frog looks like
they'll do one of two things
either they'll jump or they'll stick
their tongue out
you know i mean you can ask any little
child show me what a frog does
they'll stick their tongue out or
they'll jump it's amazing to me because
the frog has its tongue the bible talks
about tongues when it speaks about
languages and words
these unclean spirits come out of the
mouth
of the dragon words out of the mouth of
the beast and out of the mouth of the
false prophet
and it says they are the spirits of
devils working
miracles which go forth unto the kings
of the earth
and of the whole world for one reason
to gather them together to the battle of
the great day
of god almighty
there's only going to be two sides yeah
there is no
three sides there's one side or the
other jesus said you're either for me
or you're against me
[Music]
it seems like it's always been like that
though because if you think of adam and
eve right
eve gets tempted by the serpent and one
of two
things were told to her you eat that
fruit you're gonna die
the other thing that was told to earth
no you're not gonna die you can have the
fruit right that's a good point there's
no middle ground there
i mean there's nowhere to be like so it
doesn't really you know it doesn't
matter
either way or whatever like i'm choosing
to plead the fifth and you know
i'm just gonna sit in the middle it's
like no you you believe
one side of that argument about the
other
and you know that's it who do you
believe no do you know it's funny
because
the word faith in the old testament in
hebrew is an
action it's not what's in your head it's
what you do
if you believe that if you believe right
now that your house is on fire
you would not be sitting here yeah if
somebody came in you jump up and move
you would run and if you said oh i
believe it's on fire you'd be like
you're lying
is that the hebrew word for believe
that i don't i don't know i have to look
that up because i i know the word faith
but i'm not sure of the word believe
but you know how how um john 3 16 for
those that believe
will have eternal life right that belief
produced an
action i think the hebrew word of that
is pistel
and you know it's interesting too
because in the new testament
it talks about the word believe and obey
often it's the same word sometimes in
the king james it'll translate
to those that obey him and you'll look
it up and it says that believe that have
faith
and other times you'll look up the word
believe and it actually says that obey
so it's like to believe means you do if
i believe god's given me
when i was in the martial arts
i can remember one time i was in a
tournament and i got hit
really really really hard i mean hard
and i didn't want i did not want to get
up cause i went to the ground
i mean i laid down i'm sitting there
full contact with these gloves on
and i'm thinking okay i'm done i just
want to get out of the ring
and my instructor came over and he
looked down at me and he said
get up and win this fight
can we win this fight and i'm sitting
there and it's like i believed him
and i know that there was a spirit that
was speaking through him because
all of a sudden i was like man i can i
can win this fight
and i did wow and i'm like i was ready
to get i was ready to crawl out of the
ring
but i chose to believe him and to stand
up and walk
that's what jesus said wilt thou be made
whole
take up your bed and walk so that's what
god wants he
wants us to to make a choice who are we
going to believe and if we believe
then follow him that's why you were
saying that the word of god is power
yes sir it's like you're you're a
cheerleader you know amen
you can have victory you know you open
this book you feel beat down by the
world and everything but open up his
word
and he's like you can't have victory you
can stand on these promises and
i will work through you and all that
just like that guy
telling you that was like a messenger
right he was a messenger telling you you
can do this
but it was for something wicked oh yeah
sorry no go
i was just going to say in hebrews 1 14
it says are they not all ministering
spirits sent forth to minister to those
who will
inherit salvation oh i forgot that
what does it say in matthew
um i'm trying to remember
is it it's either after jesus was in the
wilderness i think it was doing jesus
was
in the it's either when he was in the
wilderness or in the garden
i can't remember exactly which one right
now but it says that
after the encounter
[Music]
that evil angels left him and like god's
angels came and ministered to him yes
i remember in the wilderness that said
that that's right
and so it's like well well what what
were they doing
like how did they minister to him like
how how would you
how would you minister to somebody like
that if you think well how do you
minister to somebody else
like if somebody is hurting or
somebody's in a bad spot
right what do you do you go to them and
you say
you know this is what god's word says
this is how god sees you're going to
make you you're going to have
you can do this you can get help and so
you think of it from the other side well
what are satan's angels doing
you know it's a different kind of
ministration yeah
right it's a perfect version of of what
their actual real function was supposed
to be
you know they've just twisted the words
right literally so if a holy angel if he
sees somebody that's
that their boyfriend just left them
their wife just left and
and they're down and discouraged holy
angels would come and say
it's going to be okay god is with you
god still loves you he's got this
his word inspires you and evil angels
would come and say
it's never going to get better your life
is is terrible your
depression to destroy you think of when
jesus was going to the garden of
gethsemane and he's met with
um elijah and moses
right what was said oh i never thought i
mean what kinds of words of
encouragement
that these humans that saw the
sort of fruition of what everybody had
hoped for
christ coming down to earth and here he
is
do you think that god sent them
specifically down there to just
give him a word of encouragement this is
the plan
that you have set into place and
you know you can do it you know i just
that's maybe a merciful thing that god
um allowed jesus to experience you know
like
yeah some people that that were in his
previous life
and you think about daniel whenever he
was uh
you know he'd see some of these
prophecies or hear some of these
prophecies
you know and the angel would be would be
sent it says to do what to help him
understand
right to and because in understanding he
would gain strength and encouragement
because
when he didn't understand the bible says
you know he was basically sick for many
days
ryo is like ill so the angel comes helps
him understand what's he going to do
he's going to feel better
right yeah so make sense of it at least
do you know i'm just going to share this
and if you if you're listening or
watching write this down it's isaiah 41
verse 10 through 20. if you're ever
having
one of those days like a really really
down day and there's darkness clouding
your mind
and things seem impossible this is a
verse that has really encouraged me and
put your name into this i'm going to
read just a couple of lines here
starting with verse 10 of isaiah 41 it
says
fear thou not eric wilson
for i am with you
be not dismayed he didn't say i want you
to try
he said be not just like he said let
there be
light the moment he said it there was
he said be not dismayed for i
am thy god that means mighty one elohim
i will strengthen you yea
i will help you yea
i will uphold thee with the right hand
of my righteousness
and my favorite part here is the next
verse
it says behold all they
that are incensed against thee shall be
ashamed and confounded
all those demons that are trying to mess
your life up they're going to be ashamed
and confounded they're going to be
confused they're going to be like man we
hit him with
everything we've got how is he smiling
and then it says they shall be as
nothing and they that are striving with
thee shall perish
thou shalt seek them and shall not find
them
even them that are contending with thee
for
they that war against thee shall be as
nothing as a thing of naught hallelujah
praise god
i just looked up the word dismay as you
were like reading in there and it
says the dictionary definition is
horrified shocked
shaken up disconcert disconcerted
confounded surprised or startled so it's
very interesting that
that it's basically saying you will not
be startled you won't be
surprised but guess who's going to get
surprised amen
the evil forces amen so we go back to
that text
in hebrew it says that the angels were
ministering
spirits to what to those that inherit
salvation yeah right so it brings my
mind
to luke chapter two so what happened
this is this is you know you're talking
about how what do angels do
what kind of mess it you know they
minister and ministering is about
messages
right yeah so in luke chapter two what
do they do
the angel said to them do not be afraid
so they are bringing comfort
right the opposite of fear and it says
for behold i bring you good tidings of
great joy which will be to all people
for there is born to you this day in the
city of david a
savior right because what do angels do
they minister to those who inherit
salvation amen right who is christ the
lord and this will be the sign to you
you will find the babe wrapped in
swaddling clothes lying in a manger
and suddenly there was with the angel a
multitude of the heavenly hosts praising
god and saying
glory to god in the highest and what and
on earth peace
goodwill towards men so they've come to
bring
minister or bring words of comfort good
will
a message of peace a message that
salvation
has come can i reject something
i did not see that it says unto you is
born this day in the city of david
a savior which is christ the lord which
is anointed
king which is what we were talking about
they're like
you don't have to fear you've got a king
that has never lost
and never will yeah do you have i mean
if you think about it all the way back
from the very beginning when adam and
eve
sin you have to figure like
that's when depression started that's
right
you know imagine being in that situation
and
and you didn't think that your actions
would
bring horrible consequences but then you
immediately realize
they do and now you're the one
responsible for setting the chain
reaction
throughout all history that would be
a heavy you know thing to weigh on your
mind yeah
and god you know comes to minister to
them
and say it's okay there's going to be a
savior i've got this
you know and the the peace the comfort
the if you don't hold on to that i mean
the rest
of your life is just miserable yeah
so that that is unreal
and you know what just hit me too before
adam and eve sinned
god was in them when they sinned
god had to step outside of them do you
remember what happened to jesus on the
cross he said my god my god
why have you forsaken me can you imagine
what you felt like for god to be inside
of you
24 hours a day seven days a week and
then all of a sudden he steps out
of separation and all of us have felt
that before yeah
and what jesus experienced was that
ultimate separation that the
the second death people will feel
so i know every person that's watching
has felt that because you can be having
the top of the world with god
and then you fall into a sin and all of
a sudden it's like you can't find him
it's like you're praying and you can't
hear him and it's
you would rather die than be like that
but god's like
trust me the devil's a liar he's lying
to you i will forgive you
just come back
[Music]
i want to show um just a couple of
examples of people that have
heard like keith was saying these fallen
angels that are
quote ministering to people they're not
ministering i should say they're
they're influencing they're the original
influencers
yes this is a lady a lot of people are
familiar with her name was h.p blavowski
she lived from 1836 to 1891.
over her lifetime she claimed to hear
the voices
of specifically two ascended masters
one of them was called morya and one was
called
kut humi and these were both
[Music]
like from tibet eastern and
they would they would speak to her they
would speak to her she was writing
automatic handwriting you've seen that
before she would be writing and all of a
sudden the song would come or the the
page would come and you hear musicians
talk about that
you know i sat down and the song just
came to us
and that's a plug for channeling spirits
part one and part two
and also false system of worship and
system of worship
name it yeah yeah i mean we've made a
a decade worth of material on showing
the messages that are coming are are
opposite of this and that's really what
we're we're in an information
war and and really you can see the war
in front of you by just looking at it
and it's
you know what is it teaching me kind of
a concept
people don't see it like that though
they go this is just entertainment it's
just fun they don't see that this is an
actual message that we're receiving
from either the light or the dark okay
you
you are getting me so excited i'm
stealing your face no no no what you
just said
it's a war what do you have to have when
you go to war you have to have
armor on yeah yeah intelligence but you
have to have armor yeah do you know what
the bible says
we fight with the sword of the spirit
which is the word of god
and we use the shield of faith and faith
comes by hearing and hearing by the word
so it's all goes back to the word we
live by the word of god
which jesus demonstrated in the
wilderness you know we think about
oh what are we going to do when the new
world order comes are we going to fight
and all this stuff but he said
our weapons are not carnal we fight
we're not battling against flesh and
blood
jesus how do you fight it is written
boom it is written and satan had to flee
every time it is written
right his words were the two-edged sword
that were
amen to work on on the falsities of that
day
amen it's funny too because jesus said
satan is a liar but i am the way the
truth and the life
so right there he's like look he's lying
i'm telling you the truth it doesn't
matter how you feel
i said i'll forgive doesn't matter how
you feel i said you'll win
wow the next person we're
going to mention here is a woman named
helen shusman she lived from 1901 to
1941.
she was the woman that authored or
co-authored
what was called the course in miracles
which oprah winfrey strongly promoted
for years probably still does
but she wrote the entire book of a
course in miracles under the dictation
and the voice of a spirit which she
claimed
said it was jesus wow when she first
started hearing the voice
she contacted um the daughter of the
occultist
edgar cayce which he originally was a
sunday school teacher
and he got sidetracked because he
started receiving information in his
head
on how to heal people he didn't know
where the information came from
and after a few years he was so far gone
he walked away from the bible and
everything
man so she contacted his daughter who
was still alive and she said
i'm hearing these voices and i'm scared
what do i do and casey's daughter said
listen to them and write down everything
they tell you to write
and she wrote this book which has went
out to millions of people through oprah
winfrey
wow wow sounds like the same thing that
some of these comic book writers
said as well isn't it interesting that
that
they're the demons have no originality
it's like they're
trying to impersonate jesus you know
what i mean it's like
they can't even come up with their own
original whatever
over here it's gotta like be somehow
tied back to
twisting your understanding of the truth
you know it's funny because you only
have light and darkness
right so you've only got truth and
everything else has to be
somehow twisting that everything has to
go back to the original
[Music]
the next uh author we have is a lady
named alice bailey that lived from 1880
to 1949.
she was the author and the
the director after blabowsky
uh died of the theosophical society
she wrote through the inspiration of a
spirit that she called the tibetan
or kohl and i don't know if i'm
pronouncing that
perfectly um it was a hindu or a tibetan
spirit that was influenced or he was
supposed to be an ascended master
and you look at what she wrote there was
much of what she wrote that was actually
is still being taught at the u.n i've
got a statement that one of the men at
uh church brought to me this past week
of her writing and this
i should have brought it with me she
actually wrote
this is not verbatim but she said that
there was
coming a manifestation of those
enlightened ones
the ones that were influencing that they
were going to manifest
physically in the flesh and she actually
wrote twice
at least and she gave the date she would
be she said it would be the year 2025.
really no kidding yeah i heard that the
2025.
yeah what's what's and i'm not
predicting dates but look guys
we're on the last few years maximum the
last few years before christ returns i
hear there's a lot of
plans for 2025 anyway just according to
the the u.n and the elite or whatever
they say by 2025 we want this to be
happening or whatever so significant
date
this one really surprised me this is a
psychiatrist a swiss psychiatrist named
carl
young he lived from 1875 to 1961.
he wrote that he had experienced many
different
visions and voices he thought some of
these were parts of his subconscious but
he believed that
others were supernatural one of the
voices that he said he heard
he named philemon this
spirit or being appeared to him when he
needed advice or guidance dr young
said quote at times he seemed almost
physically real
i walked up and down the garden with him
and he was to me what the
indians the hindus call a guru
ascended master yeah and that's
that's i mean just the language that's
even
stated here like walking with him i mean
that's like the garden
yeah i just think just think of what
what god wants to do with us he wants us
to walk with him in like
you know like two how can two uh you
know
walk together and yeah you know so it's
like
he wants us to be so close to him yeah
you see
this like parallel kind of deception
that's going on here but
it's just ever so slightly i know the
wrong direction
now we look at today and there's lots of
different images i had pictures of you
know women with crystal balls and
palm readers and name it i mean you know
there was a show that used to be on
television called medium
you know that's what a medium is there
they're a channel
for something for the spirit world to
speak through you um
so you know today it's everywhere yeah
and and not just like it was back in the
60s 70s you know and 80s now
it's being repackaged in a christian
family friendly well in pop culture
you see a lot of this demonic possession
like with beyonce or with
um what's the other girl that has the
demon roman and uh
nicki minaj that's right and how they're
they're saying you know they're
embracing this other spirit that works
through them
and using it as their gift and talent
and
you know it's terrible so like when
you're getting ready to go on stage and
performs
is sasha fierce when does she show up
usually when i hear the crowd when i put
on my stilettos
um when like the the moment right before
when you're nervous and and that other
thing kind of takes over for you uh-huh
then sasha fierce appears and my posture
and and the way i speak and everything
is different
but no is it like a process that happens
too like you were talking about the high
heels like
once the lashes go on and makeup and all
that stuff it's kind of like when i do a
movie becoming the character once you
put on the wig and once you put on the
clothes you walk
different yeah it's kind of this
character that i've created over the
years
uh-huh and how is sasha fierce different
than i am
well i know you know definitely wearing
that body suit i could never walk out
here and do that
does sasha first ever go home like um
sometimes but i
not often only only on especially
[Laughter]
shows up sometimes in the house
yeah but definitely when i'm nervous or
or um whenever i have to perform
whenever i have to
do choreography or something that's
difficult and i
it's no different from anyone else i
feel like we all kind of have that
that thing that takes over i wish i
could remember and i'll have to look
there was a man that i just read this
past week when i was you know looking
for
examples of this and he actually said be
careful
not to cast all your demons out he said
because
you might be left or you might be losing
the best thing
of you and i was like how scary
and i know keith can relate with this
it's like when i was in the martial arts
i mean
it got to the point where i thought i
was on top of the world i wasn't afraid
of anybody i mean i could do
all kinds of just really cool things i
thought
but i'm like it wasn't me it wasn't me
that was doing it and when when god
set me free which keith played that part
in the dragon revealed when that demon
was behind me
when god set me free it was like i felt
so much
joy and none of that joy had been there
before praise god
i want to show you something that uh
that the lord tells us
in deuteronomy a lot of christians say
well we don't need the old testament you
know since jesus came all that's done
away with let me tell you something most
of what jesus said came from the old
testament
almost 100 yeah in deuteronomy chapter
verse 9 through 12 the lord is speaking
to his people today
he says when thou art come into the land
which the lord thy god giveth thee
thou shalt not learn to do after the
abominations
of those nations that shall not be found
among you
anyone that maketh his son or daughter
to pass through the fire
or that useth divination which we're
going to be doing a program on that soon
the word divination actually means to
divine the future to to find out
what the future holds either by lot like
casting lots
or dice by witchcraft or by an
oracle which means you're you're going
to a medium and having the god speak
the pagan gods speak through that medium
then he says nor an observer of times
that means an astrologer i know
christians that say there's nothing
wrong with astrology even though god
said don't do it
because you're opening the door for evil
spirits to influence you
or an enchanter that's someone who
whispers a spell
or a witch which is someone who casts a
spell or
enchants or practices magic i want to
hang on this for just a second
um when we did the the documentary
called
the replacement gods there was an
interview in there
with a gentleman named is not a
gentleman actually alan moore
who wrote a bunch of comics and he was
talking about
spelling and he was like how do you put
a spell on somebody
you spell words and it's the use of the
words
was the the thing that actually cast
that spell
and so it's interesting because i think
that the devil knows that god's words
are life
to us right and so he's trying to
counterfeit that and say i'm going to
use my words to destroy you
you know it's funny in psalms 119 it
says thy word is a lamp
under my feet and light unto my path and
satan is the prince
of darkness this is what god's word says
i love you satan says he can't love you
because look what you did
so who do you believe
wow like you were talking about us
astrology is kind of
it's like a gateway you know like people
think oh it's in the newspaper
i'll just read it or whatever and and
just a second ago i said oracle what'd
you say about a oracle
an oracle like uh there was one that was
known in history called the oracle
adelphi and she was this woman that
would sit in this cave and there was
this pit that opened up they had these
vapors and she would inhale these vapors
and the
spirits would speak through her wow so
people of all ranks would go to her
to find out the future so an oracle was
where you would
go to hear the voice of god but through
another person which is the name of the
lady that
on the matrix neo yeah that's right but
also it's
it's the name of the the plastic piece
that you with the magnifying glass on a
ouija board
that's called an oracle yeah i didn't
know that yeah and then
you know just to just to throw some
things out there because we get
questions from people like well what
about this or that you know
just because it's omitted from here
doesn't mean it's okay
tarot cards and even if they're called
angel
cards yeah it's the same thing yeah as a
christian i thought
no big deal tarot card okay give me the
terror reading
and it shocked me what i saw was like so
on point and real
that i could see because a long time ago
i was actually
interested in that stuff and at this
point
i still didn't see anything wrong with
i'd never seen enough of it to impress
me that there was anything real to it so
to me it was just like a
parlor game or whatever yeah but it yeah
it shocked me
and um i can see how god had his hand
over me to protect me from seeing the
power
in the occult because i would have but
this is where it's at this is the truth
i mean
church is not doing anything for me but
these cards
tell me the future or whatever so uh
thankfully
i didn't see power in that when i would
have been able to
or at a time of my life when i would
have been sucked right into it
sky did you have something i was i was
thinking someone had mentioned to me the
other day and i was trying to look it up
and
and see um that there was a verse that
that god had said he had or had written
salvation in the stars is there a verse
that
describes something like that i've heard
that but i don't remember where it was
yeah so i was trying to i was trying to
think about it because
it's interesting to me if that's true
and i'll have to look up the verses and
see if that's true
but if god did write this plan of
salvation like like he did in
everything the scene the seed in nature
has to die
and go into the ground to come up and
give life right i mean there's the story
of salvation in
plants and things like that look at what
man
did by renaming the stars after pagan
gods
exactly right like flipping what they
really meant
and and sort of telling a pagan story
rather than the story of god's favorite
fingerprint i've heard that too you can
look at
virgo and it's really the virgin if i
was going to give birth to leo the lion
and all these things but it's not you
know
it's not leo the line or whatever but
yeah satan has come and taken something
that god made and perverted it
i mean what did people how did people
share the gospel before
moses was writing you know it's like you
look up there and you could say
look son that's you know this person and
that's you know jesus and that's this
and you could but we were never told to
look to that to tell us the future
you know even the northern cross yes
but see to look into the heavens and to
see wow
god in his providence he's revealed
everything to us right rather than
having that kind of view it's like
well that's going to tell me who i'm
going to be i'm a gemini and i need to
act like this
so this is who i need to marry if i'm
going to marry so the models totally
flipped other than
a glorification of god it's like now
that's going to dictate my
personality right
so then he goes on and he says i also
don't want you
to imitate or to practice the practices
of a charmer which is a hypnotist
or a consulter with familiar spirits
or a wizard which means a cunning or a
knowing one
a conjurer or someone who gives advice
like a guru
or a necromancer for all that do
these things are an abomination unto the
lord
and because of these abominations the
lord thy god to
drive them out from before thee
that last statement really caught me off
guard because he says
all that do these practices
are an abomination and i was like
why why does that make somebody an
abomination
and it hit me in first corinthians 6 19
it says
we are the temple of god don't you
realize your body is the temple of the
holy spirit which is in you
and i don't want to be i don't want to
be i want to be careful how i say this
if my wife and i get married and we
become
one you're one whether you're in the bed
or whether you're not in a bed you're
one all the time
[Music]
how would a man feel if his wife
while he was at work during the day if
she was letting
52 other men and half of them homeless
come into her during the day would he
want to come into her
that evening wouldn't he feel like this
is disgusting
i mean how many people have you been
with today and every day it's a new
group of 50 men
that's how god feels god is like you're
my bride
and you've opened yourself up to how
many people
read jeremiah chapter 3 he says you've
played the harlot with many lovers
yet return unto me for i am married unto
you
it's like what he did with hosea hosea
was like a prophet of god and god said i
want you to marry this woman that's a
prostitute and she kept cheating on him
and god would say
go get her back and bring her home and
love her because god was trying to show
us
i don't think the way you think even
though you're defiled
if you will just return i will wash you
and make you clean
i think it's this concept that we're
trying to get across when we talk about
superheroes or something because
superheroes are are clearly gods
repackaged and handed to us and it's
like we're paying attention to them
we're listening to their stories we're
eating their words if so to say right
you're learning about god because you're
picking up a book with words that
describe god's kingdom
what do you think you're doing when
you're saying watching a superhero movie
you're eating those words constantly
that are
coming from other civilizations and you
are essentially engaging with other gods
and god's going no no wait i want your
attention i want your eyes on me
not on that and then there's the idea of
like well i'm a christian and i can
still do that and i can still do this
right try that in your marriage amen
it's very long amen you know so i
i think that what i'm hearing as well is
god is asking for our attention he's
asking for us to
to be involved with him in an intimate
way
and and not just be you know whatever
flows around the world
you know i can remember something too
when my wife and i when when both of our
children
uh were still young if we had a salad
and then we had the main meal and then
we had dessert my wife never handed the
dessert first
because if you give me a bunch of little
debbie twinkie cakes or some kind of
you know junk food i don't want to eat
the salad
after i've got my mouth full of that you
can't sit and watch an hour and a half
movie
of hollywood and then have any taste
left in your mouth to want to open god's
word because this seems dry and boring
it's because your mind has been filled
with other spirits
good example baal pior when israel was
about to go over
the jordan river into the land of canaan
and we talked about that
you know last time about how balaam
he was you know hired to cast a curse or
speak a curse over israel
and he couldn't every time he would try
to curse him a blessing would come out
of his mouth
and the king finally dismissed him send
him home said forget it we're not paying
you anything
and balaam went home that night and he
must have really thought about it
and a spirit influenced him
and he said i got an idea i can't curse
them but i know how you can cause them
to fall
your young unmarried women to hold a
feast
outside of the camp of israel and
they're going to be playing
all that different kind of music and
they'll be wearing different clothes or
less of them
and they'll have different kind of
hairdo they'll have you know sparkly on
their face
and the young men are going to be like i
don't know what that noise is that
sounds like trouble
we better go check that out and they
went and checked it out
and i think it was what 23 000 that died
yeah i think so they went and they saw
the women
and the women were like come in and have
something to eat with us
and guys they weren't so to speak
not prostitutes they said we're friends
and one of the guys goes you know we are
supposed to be christian
you got it you got to make friends with
people otherwise you can't witness to
them we'll go in and we'll have dinner
with them and then we'll talk to them
about the three angels
and it never happened they went and had
dinner with them they ate the food that
had been sacrificed to pagan gods they
drank the
kool-aid or the punch that was a little
spiked
and pretty soon they're fornicating and
the bible actually says in first
corinthians 10
20 that when they joined themselves to
these women
they joined themselves unto baal pior
and they ate the sacrifices of the dead
now that that just kind of raises an
interesting question that
you know who you associate with you
may in turn take on whatever they're
connected to
you may open doors yeah you may open
doors yeah
like like keith said how can two walk
together except they'd be agreed
it's like what what do you have the
bible says in second corinthians i think
chapter six it says what fellowship does
light have with darkness
i mean it doesn't mean that you shun
people people will tell me they'll say
well jesus ate with prostitutes and
publicans well do you think those
prostitutes went home after having
dinner and
and went to sleep with they went home
and they were like
convicted yeah those the
republicans and tax collectors and the
prostitutes and all
they came to hear jesus because he was
offering them hope
for freedom from sin doesn't mean we're
supposed to go and hang out with him he
ministered to them
and so if we're just going to hang out
amen
you know yeah he hung out with zacchaeus
what was the result of that
just one meeting was just like you know
want to repay everything
his whole life was turned around second
corinthians chapter six it says
be not unequally yoked together that
means
joined in union together with
unbelievers
for what fellowship hath righteousness
with unrighteousness
and what communion hath light with
darkness
for we are the light of the world
you can't combine the two
spiritism now we're going to show a
little bit how these
how the devil is using his messengers
you know to
to influence through spiritualism and
spiritism
um those two words spiritism and
spiritualism
is the study and practice of
communicating with spirit entities
or the dead through the use of a medium
or a channel and i learned this from
scotty
and tommy and um back years ago when i
first saw
you know the documentary the very first
battlefield hollywood
the word medium is where we get the word
media
and everybody wants the remote control
so they can change the channel and
you're using well i don't like what that
channel is saying so let's hear what the
other channel has to say about my life
and we were channeling spirits
[Music]
this was one that that shocked me how
many people have ever heard of the beach
boys
i can remember even when i gave my life
back to the lord
i was like this is benign you know i can
i would play this for my children
alex have you never heard of the beach
boys i don't know maybe he heard the
song
good vibrations or oh that's something
yeah
maybe
[Laughter]
well they uh they were very very popular
they were a young band sort of like
the beatles but it was like they sang
about things that seemed benign
and back a number of years ago after
watching the first battlefield hollywood
and watching ivor myers
um escape from the black hole
i started paying attention and looking
up people
and come to find out and i think good
fight ministries also talked about it
these guys actually invited
charles manson to come and stay with
them for a long period of time
and he taught them how to write music so
that it would reach the masses
charles manson see now what why
i mean what would be the logical reason
for that don't you
just literally just literally tapping
into spirits
apparently i think there was a lot of
spiritualism that was happening in
hollywood and the music industry
that we don't know about or it was more
hidden back then but anyway the point
being was is
like i remember when i first came back
to the lord i was like you know my
children are
little i mean like five six seven and
eight i'm like hey guys this is a cool
song it's
it's just it's it's benign there's
nothing good there's nothing bad it's
got this happy feeling
see that's what the devil told me well
it's not for god but it's not for the
devil it's just in the middle there is
no in the middle
yeah if you're not for christ you're
against him
that's what jesus said well here these
guys
that's what they were involved with
that's why they were becoming so popular
now so let me show you this that i found
this is
the the lead singer brian wilson and he
looks really happy
and it makes me sad i mean i don't want
to mock him i'm not doing that but
it's like you look at a lot of the stars
of superstars
and people go man they're glamorous but
then you see them behind the scenes
and they're they're miserable they're
depressed
a lot of them are suicidal they're in
halfway houses all the time for drugs
and alcohol and
you know rehab clinics they're miserable
so satan is telling them my way my path
is a good path
but yet he only let you see the surface
yeah let me just read a quote to you
this was from the guardian magazine
june 2011. it says brian wilson began
hearing voices saying derogatory things
quote unquote
telling him that he was finished and
that he was going to die soon
a condition that continues till this day
that was 2011.
every day brian nods a daily
struggle he hears these voices saying
derogatory things about him
the voices were accompanied by black
depressions and
bursts of crippling irrational fear
15 years after they began he was
diagnosed with bipolar schizofective
disorder now i want to be careful when i
say this okay
i know that bipolar is a a clinical
issue i know schizophrenia is a clinical
issue
but i want to share something with you i
believe that 80
if not 80 90 of the schizophrenia
and bipolar is caused by demons
we classify it as a medical condition
but we don't understand what's causing
it
christ knew there were people that had
legitimate
diseases but he also knew many of them
had demons
evil spirits that were causing the
diseases
it says in the meantime 15 years after
he had been diagnosed in the meantime
wilson
attempted to silence these voices
himself
with cocaine and heroin what a miserable
life
what a miserable life 15 years seems
like a long time to wait before seeking
help for such terrible problems i say
brian wilson frowns again and says i
didn't need help before
then it's like you could cope with it
uh johnny depp has talked about the
demons
keanu reeves has talked about the demons
um
and this is such just a select few that
we're actually vocal about right
you know it's like sure yeah i mean if
you if you have people like the beach
boys
meddling in this kind of stuff i mean
who else has
been doing this for that's right fame
and fortune you know so
just kind of add to what you're saying
there are you know
medical things and then there's
spiritual things
a lot of times when i hear people with
multiple personalities
bipolar and stuff like that maybe not
bipolar but when they're hearing voices
i never see somebody say man i just
can't get this voice out of it
always telling me to give to the poor i
mean i just can't it's always
kill yourself kill your family it's
always these negative
things cut yourself and that's why i
think it's demonic because
when voices are telling you to do these
terrible things
it's not just like random thoughts i
mean yeah
do good do that yogurt it's not yeah
it's not silliness yeah i mean if i have
a random thought that comes to my mind
it's not
telling me to do something terrible
usually that's right
i believe uh robert williams uh the last
few years of life i mean he he was
listening a lot of voices
and i mean i mean you know
i mean he's um acting
i mean you can you can see him robin
williams
yeah i mean he's he's doing his
performance and all the stuff i mean he
can have like
i mean i mean talent gifts whatever you
want to call it me
he was so good oh i mean 50 people like
that i mean he's talking about like a
little bird and he's talking like
you know different voices and all stuff
but
his documentary that his couple years
of life i mean he was a merciable guy
listen voices you know hearing voices
and
and the last minute i mean he just
killed himself i mean i don't know
exactly
because of that or that it was terrible
you know
i mean that's what satan does he says
look you'll have a great life it'll be
free look at adam and eve
you'll be free and they were miserable
yeah
it's terrifying the bible tells us we
wrestle not against flesh and blood that
means not even your own
if you're arguing with your wife or your
husband you're not wrestling with your
wife and your husband your boss
your your best friend but with
principalities and powers
against the rulers of the darkness of
this world
against spiritual wickedness in the
heavens
i think it's good to keep this kind of a
verse um in the forefront of your mind
this is why i think it's important to
read digest eat the words of the bible
because
you know there's so many times that you
have uh
in your life little arguments whether it
be with your spouse or your
you know co-workers or your whatever and
it's like if you
if you kind of distill that down to
you know there's forces behind this
that's that's you know making us fight
each other and all this kind of stuff
right and and hopefully that will allow
you to see
people we're all caught in this this
mess of sin
and um you know maybe that'll ease or
help you find a different way to connect
with people even in the face of an
argument
and i'm learning like my wife and i we
went through a terrible ordeal for
almost five years
and now it's like when we because we're
not perfect
we still have good days and bad days and
we may be like grading on each other's
nerves but now it's like it's it's
getting so much easier where if we feel
that tension between us one of us will
say
it's okay i love you and we'll go to the
bedroom one of us
sometimes both of us but we'll go to the
bedroom and just shut the door and say
lord
right now i'm battling and i know this
is not my wife or
she'll say i know this is not my husband
we need your help right now
so i'm claiming the blood of jesus over
my spouse and over myself
and and just silence i will say a word
and pray
and god will do what we can't do and we
can do that even with a co-worker or a
boss or getting on your nerves and
you're getting you just say this is not
the person what if that person's under
attack or what if the devil is
interpreting your words for you
so you're saying i really like you that
was a good job and the devil is telling
them
i hate that i wish you'd never gotten in
the way and
he does that so when we pray
that takes the enemy's power out of the
way
it's funny because it says right there
we were wrestling not against flesh and
blood
but against spiritual wickedness and the
king james says
in the heavenly places in the greek it
actually says in the heavens
not in heavenly places but in the
heavens
in ephesians chapter 2 it says wherein
in time
past we walked according to the course
or the path and ways of this world
according to the prince of the power of
the air
and i put in parentheses airwaves
the prince of the power of the air
satellite
television how many radio stations are
playing all day long that's being pumped
into our head
you go into any store any mall you're
hearing sermons 24 hours a day
we go to church for three hours a week
and we're hearing the devil the other
how many hours you know we were just
looking
up um a particular artist who had
created a music video that was pretty
satanic
and it was like in a couple days he had
65 million views
or something like that oh 15 million
views in less than a day yeah
15. this is just let's just say that 15
million views in a day
and so we said well i wonder if any
pastor or even if the big guys like joel
olsteen you know has he ever been able
to get that kind of viewership in one
day
not even close no i mean that just shows
you right there that that
he's the he's the prince of the airwaves
his message
is the one that's getting around the
fastest
and you know he's in control of that
yeah god is more mighty
amen it says the spirits
are according to the prince of the power
of the air the spirit that now
works in the children of disobedience
the powers of the
heir the children of disobedience god
says
i want you to go to the left or i want
you to go to the right and the devil
goes no go to the left
i want you to do this and the devil says
no do this
this shocked me while i was doing
research
on different people that have heard
voices
i ran across stuff i didn't even know
was there it's called
world hearing voices day it's held
every september 14th since 2009
they have a congress for this worldwide
every single year since 2009. world
hearing voices day
i can remember when i was growing up
somebody that heard voices
normally they were put in a mental
hospital or some type of an institution
where they could get
mental help and i'm not recommending
that
[Music]
but now this group of people are saying
look just because you're hearing voices
doesn't mean something's wrong with you
it's a good thing learn to accept it and
i'm like
what i want to show you a couple of
examples this is the gentleman
in the uk his name is jonathan this is
his word he said
for decades i've told doctors that i
hear voices
i see people in places i feel sensations
and presences and as a result
i'm stressed and down all they have ever
managed to do is
translate that into experiences
hallucinations and reports anxiety
and just depression and seem to think
they've achieved something
so you can tell he's not happy because
he says i go to the doctors and
they label it but they're not able to
fix it i don't care
if you can call it something i want it
fixed
this is a lady named jeannie
she's in the usa she says hearing voices
isn't actually the problem at the heart
of my distress
was the way i was taught to respond with
fear
powerlessness and a belief that voices
are always meaningless
society has it all wrong so you see
where this is going yeah
here's a man named darren from the uk
and he's a little more honest he says
hearing voices for me
feels like a battle between good and
evil
this is from their website
a lady named joanne from australia says
my voices protect and guide me that's
terrifying
that's terrifying looking at what she
does for a living underneath her name
she's an educator and an activist yeah
you're hearing voices that are guiding
you and you are in the education
department and
or activism then i wonder what spirit's
trying to drive you
all you got to do is look at the fruit
that's right there's a lot of guided
meditation going on in public schools
now too
that's true this lady made me sad this
is a lady named dolly from the uk she
said
my voices are the sanest part of me
the madness is not listening to their
pain
i don't know this lady but just in
seeing that
one statement i saw another statement
she made online
something happened to her probably when
she was a little girl
something happened someone hurt her
and these voices are tormenting her so
once again
if i look at what she does for a living
and she's a writer and a filmmaker
you are an educator and an activist and
it's like
why are the people that are in these
positions of mass
influence hearing voices targeted
individuals
by the spirit world we want to choose
people who have
an influence in society right we need to
pray for these people because if we
start praying we don't have to know we
just say lord
those women and those men that we saw we
need to pray for them and we claim the
blood of christ over them because christ
can set them free
in romans chapter 6 verse 16 it says
know you not that to whom you
yield yourselves as servants to obey his
servants you are
to whom you obey whether of sin unto
death or of obedience unto righteousness
and that really ties into the statement
by bob dylan in the very beginning you
know it's
you got to serve somebody you got to
serve somebody and
and you know you've seen these clips of
bob dylan basically
when he was being interviewed and asked
you know why 60 minutes yeah why are you
still doing what you're doing he's like
i made a deal
long long time ago i'm keeping up my end
of the bargain
interviewer goes yeah who who's who'd
you make the deal with you know and he
goes you know the chief
of the this world and the world and so
you cannot see
yeah that's terrifying second peter
chapter 2
19 says while they promised them liberty
and freedom
they themselves are the slaves of
corruption
for of whom a man has overcome by the
same
is he brought into bondage so satan says
you'll be free
and yet you know you're in more bondage
than ever before
i love this um you have to forgive me i
don't remember where the quotes from it
may be on the next slide but it says by
becoming
one with christ man is made free there's
only one way you can
become free that's except what he did at
calvary right before he went to the
cross you know what he cried out to his
father in the garden of gethsemane john
21 he said father i pray that they all
might be one as i am in you
and you are in me that they may be one
in
us by becoming one with christ
his life becomes your life sin had no
dominion over him
it means it has no dominion over you
demons could not go
into him that means demons are cast out
of you
because they have no right to be there
and he said not my
will but your will amen because when
you're one with christ
your will becomes his will yeah satan
can't free anybody because he's in
bondage
that's right that's exactly right he's
he's in bondage to sin what christ came
to set everybody free from
that that statement's from a little book
called ministry of healing page 131
really good book inspiring
i want to close with a couple of really
good statements here and a verse
it says it is not now the work of the
sinner to make
peace with god how many people have ever
felt that way when you sinned or you
fell or you slipped or you sold yourself
into something you knew
and you're like man if i could just get
god to accept me again
listen to what this says it's not now
the work of the sinner to make
peace with god but to accept
christ as his peace and righteousness
and the quotes there in the bible
references are ephesians chapter 2 and
jeremiah 23
for thus by accepting christ as your
peace in your righteousness
which is what god says he is thus
man becomes one with christ and one with
god
there is no way by which the heart may
be made holy
save through faith in christ
you know just the stark contrast between
the light and the darkness here
is it's like god's way is so simple and
it's so
it's so look i'm not asking you to just
do this huge
like labor you don't have to climb these
mountains and just go
you know the distance all you have to do
is
take my peace and my righteousness and
accept it
yeah let me let me put it on and he's
like it has nothing to do with you
all you got to do is just accept what
i'm
offering you and the devil is so
opposite of that
he wants to give you all this stuff but
at a great infinite cost
to you and and the the work that it is
and it's like
you know it's interesting that people
fight against that so much when it's
like really god's love is so
so simple it's just waiting there for
you where satan's going to make you do
all this junk crawl through the mud do
these satanic rituals
everyday payday yeah yeah and it's like
you either die now
or you're gonna die later do you know
what's funny too because a lot of
christians
they struggle with this because they
they say it can't be that easy just to
believe on christ
and this is the key to believe on christ
is not to accept
a doctrine is to accept a life
jesus says i'm standing at the door of
your heart knocking if any man
opens the door that means you surrender
not my will but yours
i will come into you he brings
his life into us his victory becomes
ours his death to sin is ours his
resurrection
is our resurrection the walk and newness
of life
but see people want a savior but they
don't want a lord you forgive me but i
want you to stay on the outside and
jesus is like
i have to trade with you forgive means
to give in exchange for
you give me your life and i'll give you
mine i love this this is a promise in
psalm 110 verse 1 through 4
it says and the lord yahweh said unto
my lord my king sit thou
at my right hand until i make thy
enemies thy footstool
yea rule thou in the midst of thine
enemies
inside us and then he says for thy
people
shall be willing in the day of thy power
how do you know when the day of his
power is
when jesus came back from heaven after
he had risen
and ascended on high he came back you
know the first thing he said
all power has given unto me the day of
his power is now
and he promises my people shall be
willing
in the day of my power amen
jesus knows the circumstances of every
soul
the greater the sinner's guilt the more
he needs the savior
christ's heart of divine love and
sympathy is drawn out
most of all for the one who is the most
hopelessly entangled
in the snares of the enemy with his own
blood he has signed
the emancipation papers of the race
that's from ministry of healing page 89.
i love that little book
christ knows that a demon power is
struggling
in every soul that means everyone
striving for the mastery that jesus came
to break the power of satan and to set
the captives free
amen for whom the son makes free is free
indeed
hallelujah amen
i think this is our last one this is one
of my favorite verses hosea chapter 13
because he
he was speaking to me and when i read
this i was like god you wrote that to me
it says o israel put your name in there
o israel thou hast destroyed
thyself but in me is thine help
your rescue your deliverance your
freedom your healing
i will be thy king for where is any
other that may save thee
in all of thy cities praise the lord the
next one says
when the soul surrenders to christ a new
power
takes possession of the new heart
when you surrender to christ he gives
you his heart
your heart is clean because it's his
heart you become one
one flesh like adam knew his wife eve
and they were made one flesh
christ says you're my bride when you
become one with me
we become one flesh a change is wrought
which man can never accomplish for
himself
it is a supernatural work bringing a
supernatural element into human nature
the soul that is yielded to christ
becomes his
own fortress which he holds in a
revolted world
and he intends that no authority shall
be known
in our heart but his own
a soul thus kept in possession by the
heavenly agencies
is impregnable to the assaults of satan
for greater is he that is in us than he
which is in this world
yea we are more than conquerors through
him that loved us
and with him there can be no such thing
as failure loss impossibility
or defeat for we can do all things
through him who strengthens us amen
hallelujah amen amen
praise god amen god is good
so you know what we have got to act as
those messengers like keith was saying
when we see somebody even at the grocery
store you're checking out and you see
and you can see them and god will tell
you they need a word of hope yeah
you tell them you reach over and you say
ma'am the lord loves you and he wanted
me to tell you that
don't worry can i pray with you you know
just let the lord lead you but speak
life jesus says in proverbs he says we
have the power of
death or life in the tongue speak life
and i'm having to learn to do that you
know with my own family you know
don't speak the negative it's amazing
even at church
um i've been had a fortunate opportunity
to just be a greeter at the door
and to observe how people come into
church you know some people are very
excited they're smiling and they want to
stop and they want to say hi to and some
people walk in
in this just gloom and you can feel
the like little black cloud over them as
they're walking in
and when you say hello to them that that
may be their only interaction that
they're going to have
all day long and um
you know just just to give them a little
word of hope i'm glad that you're here
today you know and just see how people
like like respond to that and it's been
really neat i mean i think that we need
to do more of that if you see somebody
down
saddened whatever i mean yeah like you
said walk over to them and give them a
little bit of encouragement
um it's by carrying around tracks and
things are very important
you know and tracks with different uh
topics on them you know in a confusing
world like today where
people have lost their jobs and don't
know what to do you know
it would go a long distance to say hey
you know what and god's got you
yeah i mean just give him a chance amen
yeah and words matter you know they do
that's why we have the words of the
bible because words matter and
that's the words we need to stick to the
words we need to think about the words
we need to share
so this program has been about
two kingdoms and each one of us have a
choice on which kingdom we're going to
be in
and so as you've heard this discussion
we hope that you have
made the choice or will make the choice
to be a part of christ's kingdom
and if that's something you're thinking
about doing and you're struggling with
that
we ask that you would reach out to us
you know put a comment in the
in the section below or send us an email
or get a hold of us on social media
we'd like to help you make that decision
and so we hope that you've pretty
appreciated this
message and that it has ministered
to you and we hope that you will join us
the next time this has been led live and
we will see you again
i love it i mean i can't watch enough of
this the duelist who they say
can speak with the spirits the sins will
destroy the commandments forever a
suspicious
list of names prompts an investigation
at a local school and concern for
parents the death note is derived from a
japanese animated show the girl told
authorities she got the idea from a
cartoon network show
mom it's mr satan i recognize that voice
anywhere
[Applause]
hey
um
[Music]
you